aujourd'hui je vous présente un nouveau
smartphone un nouveau smartphone qui
n'est pas commercialisé ici en europe
c'est le remy de remy de qui un
smartphone d'entrée de gamme alors il ya
différents smartphones chez remy et une
remy 1 qui arrive aux moines mais le
remy 2 au mois de septembre le rugby de
pro qui arrivait mais je n'ai pas encore
pas mal de produits des produits qui
sont plutôt pas mal d'entrée de gamme le
design est bien réussit ça joue pas mal
maintenant elle concerne ton de dire en
commentaire ce que vous en pensez
[Musique]
avant toute chose on a reçu un coup
aujourd'hui qui vient d'arriver
olalala des coques de tous les côtés
dans quelques jours va arriver au studio
l'iphone 10 r on va le tester et
l'ajustement sérinophile de kim on voit
ces différentes coques pour tester sur
l'iphone dit m
il ya pas mal de choses cool plein
coques des protections d'écran tout ça
bon ça on va le détailler lors du test
dont je vous invite à faire une seule
chose pour voir tout ça et pour
découvrir cet iphone 10r et tout savoir
de sucer bien évidemment à vous abonner
je vous présente aujourd'hui leur hilmi
ii il me faut savoir que c'est une
marque qui vient à la base de haut pour
un des big boss un des pontes chez au
pot qui a monté une mire il vit
aujourd'hui une entreprise indépendante
et qui vend des smartphones sur le
marché indien indonésien et vietnamiens
donc c'est pas du tout en produits que
vous pouvez commander en france vous
pouvez l'acheter effectivement sur
amazon
1 il est absolument pas dispo sur amazon
france sur un amazon en europe
il est dispo sur aucun site de vente en
ligne accessible ici directement depuis
la france pour vous faire livrer d'un
point de vue purement design vous avez
un smartphone qui est relativement ip
fait 8,2 mm d'épaisseur 156,2 de hauteur
une largeur 75,6 le poids est pas
complètement dingue il fait 168 g vous
avez dessus un écran de 6,2 pouces qui
fait 15 8 centimes et ça vous intéresse
il occupe 80 8,8 pour cent de la face
avant c'est bien évidemment un écran lcd
une dali ps est un format 19/9 plutôt
pas mal une résolution hd + 1520 par 720
pixels
c'est un smartphone vraiment d'entrée de
gamme si on devait le convertir roupies
en euros il coûterait à peine à peu près
100 euros 100 et quelques euros donc
s'avérer pas chercher bien loin
peut-être qu'avec la tva on arriverait à
150 euros
mon avis guère plus en terme de
performance c'est pas extraordinaire on
a un score de 76 1809 sur entre tous
qu'il faut dire qu'à l'intérieur vous
avez un snapdragon 450 cadencé maximum à
1 bienvenus
giguère vous avez deux versions
disponibles soit 3 giga de ram 32 gigas
de stockage soit 4 gigas de ram 64 giga
de stockage dans les deux cas extensible
jusqu'à ce giga par contre l'autonomie
est pas mal avec une batterie de 4230
millions terreur vous pouvez tenir une
journée bien évidemment ça dépend de
votre utilisation si vous avez une
utilisation un peu de sauvages
extrêmement intensive
ça va être un peu compliqué mais sinon
une journée sans aucun problème du point
de vue de l'appareil photo vous avez ici
une double caméra 13 mégapixels + 2
mégapixels a qu'une ouverture de f 2.2
la 2 mégapixels servira pour le mode
portrait sinon vous êtes surtout la 13
mégapixels ou pas extrêmement lumineux
et à l'avant vous avez une caméra de 8
mégapixels avec une ouverture de f 2.2
pareil pas très lumineux autant la
caméra arrière fonctionne pas trop mal
le rendu est pas mauvais tu peux vous
montrer ce qu'on peut faire avec en
termes de photos autant la caméra de
celle ci et il faut le dire assez
dégueulasse
voilà il n'y a pas d'autre terme des
films est avec vous allez voir c'est
très pixélisé c'est pas terrible on
reconnaît quand même les visages sa
traque les visages ça ça marche pas trop
mal
vous avez la possibilité d'avoir du hdr
dessus vous avez l'effet de profondeur
là qui est l'âne qui vous fait le flou
mais le flou est vraiment pas terrible
alors bon ça c'est pareil il n'est pas
sur une terrasse d'un gros on n'a pas
trop trop lui en demander
vous avez la possibilité de régler
standard plein écran comme vous voulez
le flash le cl ça vous avez également de
l'intelligence artificielle avec des
petits stickers alors sa traque bien
votre visage seul recoller donc ça vous
met des petits stickers
c'est assez marrant vous avez les
autocollants l'organe à différents on
peut avoir l'air malin avec un chat des
lunettes ça c'est ça c'est le côté
rigolo ça marche très très bien de la
vidéo du tag l'afp il y aurait voulu
marquer là c'est pas time lapse et le
times relate donc vous pourrez faire si
vous voulez votre le times las c'est
tout à fait possible pouvait filmer en
full hd 1080p 1920 par 1080 en 30 images
par seconde alors le rendu est pas
extraordinaire s'est pas complètement
fou ça fait le job
on est une fois de plus sur un
smartphone d'entrée de gamme voilà cinq
ans parce que j'aime pas trop
c'est la caméra parce que pour que cette
caméra vent je trouve pas de bonne
qualité
alors là ça a l'air à peu près de
fonctionner ça me faire mentir le point
se fait pas trop sur moi un moment il ya
une vraie reconnaissance de visages
alors ici dans des conditions qui sont
vraiment optimale c'est très éclairé
donc forcément ça devrait être un peu
mieux là dessus mais moi je ne suis pas
convaincu je mate aussi des zones un peu
plus
bon jeu décalé on va venir la voilà la
ya de l'ombre
alors forcément c'est son il y à du
bruit ça c'est aussi normal il va
chercher à compenser voilà moi je ne
suis pas un très très très grand fan de
cette caméra ça c'est un peu pour un peu
négatif
bon maintenant on va jeter un coup
d'oeil du côté de la photo côté photo
c'est pas extraordinaire bon néanmoins
ça fait le job on est sur un smartphone
d'entrée de gamme
on va pas trop lui en demander il faut
pas trop être difficile avec lui vous
avez un androïde 8.1 oreo mais la
surcouche seco leur os 5 points il ya
pas mal de petits réglages qui sont
marrants sur ce col hors us lorsque vous
allez fouiller un petit peu dans les
paramètres
ce qui est sympa c'est d'aller dans les
services pratiques où il n'avait pas mal
de choses et des touches de navigation
alors vous pouvez naviguer avec vos
touches virtuelles que vous avez en bas
vous aussi faire la navigation par
gestes pas mal de possibilités
retour sur les deux côtés geste simple
retour droite au retour à gauche là ya
pas mal de petites choses si on se met
par exemple là dessus on peut naviguer
comme ça pour avoir ces retours c'est
vrai que c'est pas mal ça nous rappelle
des navigations de ce que vous pouvez
avoir directement chez apple
vous n'avez pas un chrome comme ce qu'on
peut retrouver classiquement vous avez
carrément opéra vous pouvez bien
évidemment venir op zoom est ici vous
voyez que ça deviens cros paix au niveau
de l'encoche au regard certains
smartphones où ça s'arrête sur le côté
il ya des smartphones comme celui là où
ça vient aussi au niveau de l'encoche ça
fonctionne il ya un bouton sur le côté
bon là ça fonctionne on n'a rien à lui
reprocher là dessus
au point de vue audio
[Applaudissements]
vous avez un haut parleur mono qui se
situe juste là bon ça fonctionne c'est
pas complètement dingue ça marche en
termes de connectique vous avez du micro
usb une prise jack qui situent juste là
le bouton pour venir à l'allumer et
l'éteindre
les boutons de volume sur le côté ici
votre tiroir de cartes sim et à
l'arrière votre capteur d'empreintes
digitales
à noter sur ce smartphone vous avez la
possibilité de mettre une double carte
sim ça hop je le sors bien par là vous
avez donc un double lecteur de carte sim
plus une carte microsd qui peut venir se
loger là ça c'est plutôt bien de pouvoir
retrouver tous directement dans ce
smartphone
ça c'est un point fort vous avez du
bluetooth 4.2 il est dispo dans cette
couleur noir en bleu et en rouge
également
je trouve plutôt pas mal le point drugs
ex aux smartphones c'est que il est
dispo sur aucune place de marché ni sur
amazon ni sur cdiscount nulle part s'est
pas trouvée je vous met néanmoins un
lien du site de remy en bas dans la
description c'est un smartphone d'entrée
de gamme
on va se le dire on se ment pas c'est
pas une bête de complète je trouve qu'il
a vraiment un très joli design à
l'arrière je ne pense pas qu'il ait de
certification européenne du fait déjà
que vous n'avez pas les petits pictos en
bac on retrouve usuellement sur tous les
autres smartphones néanmoins je trouve
ça plutôt cool de vous présenter
aujourd'hui un produit un peu différent
que ce qu'on peut retrouver
classiquement sur le marché un produit
qui vient indirectement de au procès de
parme un petit peu de voir ce qui se
passe sur le marché et notamment du côté
de l'inde donc ça franchement c'est cool
aussi
donc voilà pour ce crime hideux dites
moi ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que vous connaissiez déjà la
marque remy est ce que vous en aviez
déjà entendu parler sur une chaîne dans
des médias quelque part est ce que ça
vous dit quelque chose
et est ce que si ce produit arrivée en
france pouviez acheter directement en
france est ce qu'il pourrait vous
intéresser
est ce que vous trouvez en tout cas ce
smartphone cool design ça va vous
marquez tous ces commentaires je vous
invite bien évidemment rester connecté
parce que comme je vous le disais il ya
l'iphone dit serre qui arrive d'ici
quelques jours on va en parler on va le
tester
on va le regarder un peu tous les côtés
va y avoir aussi d'autres produits va y
avoir le one + 6 t qui va arriver aussi
d'ici quelques temps dès que le samsung
galaxy à 7 arrivera et sera disponible
on va le tester on va essayer de tester
aussi le chiot me mis 8 lightman ya pas
mal de produits pour cette fin d'année
on va regarder aussi du côté des google
pixels progrès pixels 3xl on va essayer
ce faire le mec 20 programmes ya pas mal
de produits pas mal d'ordinateur
également qui arrivent pas mal de monde
connecté d'objets connectés de casse pas
mal de trucs donc ça c'est super cool en
tout cas merci à vous d'être toujours
plus nombreuse toujours plus nombreux on
n'est pas très très loin des 100 milles
il nous reste 20 mille vingt mille à
venir nous rejoindre 20000 personnes qui
nous rejoignent et on arrivera au cent
mille abonnés dont je compte vraiment
sans vous pour partager un axe avec
plein de monde parce que plus on est de
fous plus on rit voilà soyez ça je vous
embrasse à très bientôt bisous
[Musique]